are you ready for this performance oh oh
yes we are ready and so excited 24 hours
later and we still cannot get over Lady
gaga and Bradley Cooper's steamy a star
is born performance at the Oscars we're
far from the shell oh no no we're no
Jack and Allie but Lady gaga and Bradley
Cooper's chemistry is undeniable on that
stage you guys the pair's intimate duet
only added fuel to those rumours that
maybe they're more than friends what did
you think of Lady Gaga and Bradley
Cooper's performance I was like are they
doing it
it was so good even Bradley's ex-wife
Jennifer Esposito who he was married to
for less than a year weighed in on the
speculation she commented on this post
from David Spade which he captioned is
there any chance these two aren't saying
it like it is right Jennifer simply
responded with a cryptic one-word answer
writing ha in the comments I mean I like
the way you said that the ha yeah but it
was just making me think because it was
such a short response was this a
fantastic laughs you know was this a
silly laugh was it a ha or a ha yeah you
know what much left to be interpreted
right absolutely
to be fair almost everyone had something
to say about this me mobile moment take
a look at what they said at the Oscars
after parties it was phenomenal
phenomenal and just so intimate and
beautiful and yeah I was stunning that
little moment they had it at the end
when they they had they looked into each
other's eyes and was done and I just
think it's like they have a bond that I
think they'll be able to share for the
rest of their lives you know where I
think if they're in their 50s 60s 70s
whenever they see each other whenever
their paths crossed I'll always have a
special I think they've got a really
special relationship it's beautiful
watch Lady gaga and Bradley Cooper do
their performance well I did
yes Oh chill it just took my breath away
that song the simplicity in that lyric
as well as the simplicity and the melody
is so astonishing it really really hits
right here it's such a beautiful song
and the chemistry and the [ __ ] well the
chemistry we are gonna talk about that
conveying the evening with other people
exactly Billie exactly this is so
awkward
Bradley isn't a serious relationship
with arena shake and they share a
one-year-old daughter I know let's look
at rest guys and Bradley told et he
prepared for his shallow performance by
singing to his baby girl cute did you
practice busting into your little girl a
little bit
oh I sang first of all we edited the
movie below her room
so she was in the native with noise for
the first six months of her life yeah
that's great music smarter and smarter
or so like never want to hear that sound
drag with the rest of your life
one reason fans are running with the
rumor is because Lady Gaga is newly
single just days before the Oscars news
broke that she called off her engagement
with Christian Kirino I mean I could
understand why people are running with
this one but a source told et quote
during the filming of the movie their
relationship was in a honeymoon phase
Christian was supportive of her career
after the film was complete her schedule
became non-stop and that's when they
started drifting apart she still loves
him very much
and truly cares about him our source
adds Gaga and Christian are amicable
they still talk to each other and it's
heartbreaking for both of them that it
didn't work out yeah that's a tough
thing now one day after the duet Lady
Gaga tweeted this nothing could be more
special than sharing this moment at the
Oscars with a true friend and artistic
genius there is a lot of love there and
we'll leave it at that just true friends
of course we'll have all the latest
Bradley and Gaga news so be sure to
subscribe to all things et so you don't
miss it
yep guys until next time I'm at Kourtney
underscore Tesman oh and I'm at Halle
underscore Stephens bye guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]